it's great to be joined today by John
kinder Fogg who joined Palo Alto
Networks as field CTO after eight and a
half years at Forrester Research where
he was a vice president and principal
analyst on the security and risk team
considered one of the foremost
cybersecurity experts in the world very
well known for creating the zero trust
model of cybersecurity which we'll talk
about so John we recently spoke to Molly
McHugh about information warfare and
sort of some ancillary or tangential
issues that are related to cyber
security in many ways let's start maybe
more broadly with when we talk about
cyber security what are we talking about
and what are the sort of recent concerns
in the field
well cyber security is becoming an all
incomes encompassing term for bad things
that happen on networks whether they're
public networks or private networks and
how do you secure the systems and the
data the devices all that kind of stuff
so it's a very broad term that it could
include things like cyber warfare all
types of hacking data breaches so it's
it's not very specific but it does seem
to resonate with people so they
understand that the term is about the
cybers right we're not trying to protect
the cyber as we're trying to protect
data we're trying to protect assets
though what are the sort of day-to-day
ways in which the average user of
Technology you have a smartphone you
probably have it connected to both
social networks and your email you're
regularly browsing websites on it you
have some you know regular computer use
as part of your job as well as
personally what are the biggest
cybersecurity sort of concerns that
would impact the average person in that
way here's the deal David I don't think
that the average person can really be
concerned about cybersecurity and live
their life I think that we spend too
much time blaming the victims of
cybersecurity intent instead of trying
to fix the fundamental
problems in the systems that allowed
these kinds of you know negative
consequences of using technology to
happen so I'm not I'm not a person who's
going to give people a lot of advice on
their home usage I mean there's a few
things that are that are pretty simple
don't use an unlocked cell phone for
example get your get your applications
from the store of the you know the phone
manufacturer because at least they've
done some vetting of the technology and
every once in a while something will
slip by but think of the store as a
whitelist for the applications you
should use those are some of the simple
things but the rest of it is way too
complicated even for the the top people
to always protect themselves let alone
the average user who just wants to get
their day-to-day job done so is
cybersecurity really at more of an
institutional issues when we're talking
about governments and and corporations
that are providers of either hardware or
software connectivity is that really
where the crux of the issue is
absolutely those are the people who are
going to have to do it right you you
just it's too complex for us to push it
all all the way to the edges of the user
so I liken it to trying to decide
whether or not to go into a building if
it's safe or not you know do you look
and try to figure out well should I go
into this restaurant will the building
fall down while I'm eating lunch no
that's the job of some other profession
in that case you know the civil
engineering and code enforcement and all
that kind of thing and so that's what
eventually cybersecurity is going to
have to be it's going to have to be the
civil engineering and the code
enforcement of of the Internet of
connectivity to make sure that people
can use this technology in a safe and
secure fashion before we move into
talking about zero trust based on your
observation of the way in which
technology is developing what
on the horizon in terms of the types of
cyber security concerns that may surface
which were not even necessarily dealing
with right now is there anything you can
sort of paint a picture for us of
regarding in terms of on the horizon
well the horizon is is limitless from
the the bad guys and girls perspective I
mean where we're gonna see it a lot of
it is in the so-called Internet of
Things your your smart thermostat we've
seen it with the IP cameras that have
been used in the mirai botnet anything
that exists technologically people with
malicious intentions are going to try to
abuse that technology for their own
purposes and we should never
underestimate the threats just because a
threat doesn't exist today doesn't mean
that it can't exist tomorrow and and and
it's limited by the the by the
imagination of the adversary this is an
adversarial business and so we're always
a little bit behind if you're you're on
the good guy the good girl side
are there any institutions or
organizations that that really seem to
be sort of throw actively at the maximum
point they could be and I guess to sort
of contextualize that we've we saw so
many cyber security breaches during 2016
we you know everything from the Justice
Department and the IRS snapchat Yahoo
and 500 million accounts or something
like that I mean is there a type of
institution that seems to be better
protected I don't know if there's a type
it's it's an attitude and it's a it's an
Enlightenment you know Yahoo they used
to call the the security people the
paranoids
oh you're paranoid you're just you know
that will never happen to us only
because we couldn't imagine it happening
to us but it did happen to them and it
cost
Yahoo almost the entire value of its
company so you just have to realize that
this is in a different landscape a
different world it doesn't
world isn't at all like the analog world
and all of the the analogies that we try
to do to make it understandable to us
just don't work you know you're you're
living in the same bad neighborhood is
every single attacker on the world
there's no suburbs on the internet you
can't hide and so you're going to have
to protect yourself let's talk a little
bit about the zero trust model that you
developed what is that for people who
aren't familiar with it let's start
there the zero trust model is a a new
model of cybersecurity that says that
the old model where users and networks
and devices inside of a of a perimeter
inside of a company or an organization
are trusted and everything outside of
that organization is untrusted and
therefore we only have to protect from
attacks coming from the outside and and
the mantra was originally trust but
verify which everybody says well Ronald
Reagan said that and he actually didn't
he was making a joke where he he uses a
Russian proverb
speaking in Russian and says oh that of
course is translated as trust but verify
and everybody laughs when he gives this
speech because they know the essence of
the Russian proverb is not trust but
verify but never trust at all and so
when I started looking at at what was
the fundamental problem the fundamental
problem is that we embedded trust into a
system that not only doesn't need trust
to function by functions poorly because
we add trust to it interesting and from
a practical perspective what are some of
the sort of bullet points of how this
functions well the first thing is we
need to understand that no people are
ever on networks so people say you're
saying that people aren't trustworthy
and I'm not saying that that's a that's
a discussion issue you should go back
and have with Julius Caesar I'm saying
that people aren't packets no person
who's ever been on a network you and I
David we're not on the network right now
there are packets traversing networks
that are
to come from identities that may or may
not belong to us but we're not on the
network so we're not doing anything to
impugn people's trustworthiness we're
just saying we're going to treat each
and every packet exactly the same and
when we do that that just opens up a lot
of doors and a lot of Revelations and so
we can we can inspect all the traffic we
can log all the traffic we can put much
more granular controls on it and most
importantly we start at the thing we're
trying to protect I used the analogy of
the u.s. Secret Service The Secret
Service knows three things that we don't
know in cybersecurity they know who the
president is they know where the
president is and they know who's
supposed to act access to the president
if I asked almost any corporation about
the data or assets that they need to
protect they can't tell me those three
things they don't know what to protect
they don't know where the things that
they're supposed to protect are and they
don't know who's supposed to have access
to the things that they're supposed to
protect
therefore they just push all the
controls to some edge and hope that
maybe they catch something bad happening
before it's too late last thing I want
to touch on there are some who say that
businesses sort of have a free market
natural incentive to regulate themselves
in a way that will make them not
problematic or dangerous to employees
customers the environment etc and in my
view is that that's been pretty widely
debunked when it comes to corporations
and cybersecurity does such a natural
interest exist to protect all data
customers employees etc or does that not
exist and it would need to sort of be
mandated by some kind of regulatory
apparatus it should exist because all
regulations and compliance in my view is
a failure of corporate governance we
didn't get ahead of the problem and so
there will always be more and more
governance added to it and until people
realize that it you know security cyber
security is a pay me now or pay me a lot
more later kind of business
and if you understand that then maybe
those incentives can can be in place
secondly though and I think the big
thing that's that's changing is that
CEOs are and leaders of organizations
are getting fired because of data
breaches we saw that with target that
was the first one that really put a
shockwave through the entire industry
because suddenly it wasn't just oh I'm
gonna fire the security guy who didn't
do a good job even though I didn't give
him a budget to do a good job it was oh
the board has to protect themselves so
they're gonna get rid of the leader and
whether that's the CEO of Target or
whether that's Katherine Archuleta of
the OPM Office of Personnel Management
or or the head of Sony I mean there's
just so many times that people have
gotten fired the leaders of companies or
organ organizations have gotten fired
and so that does change the incentive
structure pretty pretty strongly but
there still will always be regulations
because we're always going to be cheap
that's just human nature
indeed it is we've been speaking with
John kinder vog Palo Alto Networks field
CTO thanks so much for talking to us
about this thank you very much David